hola buen día pues este debate que
durará tiene 66 segmentos de 15 minutos
que será de manera inusual no se
estrecharán las manos debido a la
pandemia tiene varios temas centrales
uno de ellos es kobe 19 la respuesta que
cada uno de los candidatos tiene en sus
plataformas para hacer frente a esta
crisis al desempleo y volver a tener
trabajos en los estadounidenses también
otro de los temas centrales por supuesto
será la economía pero igualmente el tema
de la igualdad racial después de las
grandes protestas que se registraron en
toda la nación exigiendo cambios y
reformas al interior de los
departamentos de policía igualmente es
muy posible que veamos preguntas sobre
la declaración de impuestos de donald
jones y el gran escándalo que ha
generado debido a la cantidad tan baja
que ha tenido que pagar el presidente en
materia de impuestos otro de los temas
serán la corte suprema- y lo que
califican los demócratas e incluso el
presidente
de los eeuu como una urgencia para
alumbrar a un nuevo miembro y que sea
aprobado por el senado al interior de la
corte suprema- así que será una mezcla
de los temas principales de seguridad
nacional pero también de los temas más
polémicos que han generado rivalidad
entre los dos partidos y vienen a
contarnos cómo sigue a cada candidato a
este debate en términos de imagen de
aceptación pública
bueno las últimas encuestas muestran que
yo bailé lleva una ventaja de entre 6 a
7 puntos a donald trump a nivel nacional
sin embargo esto varía por estados por
ejemplo en florida el presidente de
donaldson le lleva una ventaja de tres
puntos a bailén y es un estado clave
para ganar las elecciones presidenciales
por ejemplo para el voto latino la
última encuesta de esta semana muestra
que definitivamente va a ir en el lleva
una ventaja más amplia de 42 puntos pero
hay 26% de los latinos que votarían por
donald trump sobre todo como lo
mencionaba en el estado de florida así
que los dos candidatos se llegan a
enfrentarse en este tan esperado
debate el presidente en medio de
críticas por el manejo que ha dado a
esta pandemia y bailén fortalecido
también por esta desventaja que tiene el
mandatario de tener digamos estas
dolorosas cifras de ser el líder a nivel
mundial con más muertes
coronavirus y casos alrededor del mundo
ya nada acá tenía muchísimas gracias por
este completísimo reporte desde
washington eeuu